Dudley in the West Midlands one of the
birthplaces of the Industrial Revolution
once upon a time this was Britain's
manufacturing heartland not anymore
people used to come to this thriving
market towns a shop now most of the big
names have fled the high streets the
general demise started with the
out-of-town shopping center so many
across the country but if we could get
some more footfall back into the town
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy if you
haven't got the shops you don't get the
people you haven't got the people you
don't get the shops people are very
conscious of their spending power even
just a few pounds I think twice about
spending gifts particularly in Dublin
particularly this story of economic
decline might not be the one you hear
about in London but it is the story of
many of Britain's towns and here is
elsewhere the road to austerity has been
pockmarked with pain an epidemic of
potholes one sign of the cuts local
authorities have been forced to make the
government has pushed us into a position
where we have been as politicians
spending most of our time trying to come
up with palliative savings that our
communities will support if we weren't
in this position we would be investing
more money in in potholes
we'd be investing more money in keeping
our communities clean we'd be looking at
new ways of investment with the Prime
Minister having promised to end
austerity to govern for the left behind
all eyes are now on the Chancellor the
good news is the economy while not going
gangbusters is at least looking
relatively stable
[Music]
if all the narrative about decline the
UK still has many advanced manufacturing
companies
companies like Mosely Brothers which
makes parts and tools for the world's
car giant's field it looks quite good at
the moment and has been for the last
four or five years it's been quite
buoyant and I think that obviously the
brexit there's a bit of uncertainty per
and if it the main problem with that
would be if agreement isn't reached then
consumer confidence might dip a bit but
in terms of directly affecting us I
think we're good relationships with our
customers and I see that continuing into
the future as well like many other post
industrial towns Dudley voted
overwhelmingly to leave and brexit is
likely to be the elephant in the room
next week the Chancellor unable to make
major decisions until we know what kind
of a deal we're going to get but he
might have a bit more room for giveaways
than normal
here's the intriguing thing over the
past six months the amount of money
coming into the Exchequer has been far
more than anyone expected which raises
two intriguing prospects first of all
might the Chancellor be able to do all
those things he wants to do ending
austerity putting more money into the
NHS without having to raise new taxes
and secondly might the economy actually
be growing a bit faster than everyone
thinks it is in next week's budget the
Chancellor may be able to tell a
cautiously positive story about the
economy as brexit looms large can he
help give hope to the towns which have
been left behind ed conway Sky News in
Dudley